And now it's the old scout master.
We were camping last weekend and I was sharing a tent with one of my assistant scout masters.
before he batted down
He took two coins out of his pocket and he put them under his pillow.
I saw that and I said it's kind of interesting.
But the next night he did it again,
Took two coins out of his pocket, put them under his pillow
And I said: you know, I saw you do this last night and doing it tonight.
I got to know why
And I said: well, those are my sleeping quarters,
Those are my sleeping quarters.
They don't seem to be getting any better.
It's podcast number 98..
Hey,
Hey, Clark, this is Chad Fisher. in Little Own, Texas,
I'm a varsity coach for Team 63..
Just listening to podcasts 97 from the advancement team. first of all, Gray podcast.
I don't know how anybody couldn't love the new guide for advancements, because it essentially
takes all the power away from those rogue scout leaders and puts all the power back
to the boy to have a boy-led Eagle Scout project and a boy-led advancement process in scouting.
I get straight.
I love it.
I'm grateful for it.
Thanks, Clark,
Hi,
Hey,
This is Clark Green.
Welcome back to the Scout Master Podcast.
Thanks for getting in touch, Chad.
I'm glad you enjoyed the interview we did about the guide to advancement.
Let's take a look in the mailbag here and see who else got in touch.
Frank Maynard wrote: I enjoyed the chat with the advancement team members.
Their insight into the types of cases that make it up to the national level was interesting,
as was hearing about the process that went into rewriting the guide to advancement.
Tim Begley wrote and he said: I'm a scouting volunteer since 1999, currently finishing
my second year as scout master for our troop in Omaha, Nebraska.
I found your podcast website last week and have found a great deal of information
that I find very useful.
Thank you and keep up the great work.
Well, thank you, Tim.
Thanks for the kind words.
A particular interest was your recent podcast about the Patrol Leaders Council.
I'm discussing your views with other leaders and getting their feedback.
Can you point me to a podcast or other resources where you discuss the senior patrol leader
Our troop currently appoints one?
Many of our adult scouters are adamant that it remain that way.
Personally, I'd like to see it become an elected position.
Your direction is appreciated.
I've been picking and choosing from the most recent podcast, but I think it would
take a long time to get through them all
To write about that. Tim, there's 98 now,
Hey, with this one there's 98..
That means in two podcasts we're going to be at big podcast number 100..
Tim, what I'd suggest you do is listen to the podcast where I interviewed the
authors of Working the Patrol Method.
I think it's somewhere in the 40s there.
I'll make sure to have a link to it in the post that contains this podcast,
And I also got to recommend the book that they wrote.
I think it's. you know, it's a great piece of work and it will give you a
really great overview of the patrol system, the senior patrol leaders job
and how to operate from a boy run perspective.
So I think that would probably be some of the most useful information
that I have online to help you out there.
Thanks for being in touch and thanks for your encouragement and kind words,
Always appreciated.
In this edition of the Scoutmaster podcast, we're going to have in
Scoutmastership, in seven minutes or less, a discussion about the
patrol leaders council and planning.
This is one of those perennial subjects that we need to keep on discussing
because it's one of the more difficult things to get right.
I know I'm still working at it, as most people who are running a
successful scout troop out there.
We keep working at planning and training our youth leadership
and mentoring them through the process,
And there was a Google plus discussion that I think we're going
to find useful and we're going to listen to that and Scoutmaster
ship in seven minutes or less.
Then we're going to move on to a quick email question about the
requirements for arrow of light applying to the scout rank, to
the scout badge rank.
So I think that's going to be enough for this podcast.
Let's get started, shall we?
Scoutmaster ship in seven minutes or less.
So if you haven't joined the exclusive Scoutmaster CG circle
over on Google plus, go to Google plus, look for Scoutmaster CG
and add me to your circle and I will reciprocate and add you to
the Scoutmaster CG circle.
There's been some good discussions and back and forth
and questions being asked over on Google plus and I wanted to
make you prove it. in one of those questions and some of the
answers that came in about them,
Todd Grady on Google plus wrote this. he said: while our
Scouts are very active and enthusiastic, their ability to
plan and follow through is sorely lacking.
So I'm going to stop there for a second and I'm going to let
everybody nod their heads in appreciation-
Yes, that is true of 99.99% of the people who are listening
here. their Scouts are very active and enthusiastic, but
their ability to plan and follow through is sorely lacking.
You're not alone.
All right, let me get back to Todd's question here.
We hold a yearly planning conference and the Scouts come
up with a great schedule for the year,
But if it weren't for the adult leaders, the events would
never come close to happening.
Every month we have to walk the youth leaders through every
detail of making a camp out happen.
We're always down to the wire, organizing transportation and
food and things like that.
When we still manage to make the events happen, it's a
stressful experience and it's mostly carried out by the
adults.
So my question is, as adult leaders and mentors, how can
we guide these Scouts to do a better job of organizing
events?
I've tried making a point by letting them fail, which
only results in hikes and camp outs being canceled,
But that only results in a poor program and it didn't seem
to have much impact on them.
My desire is that we have a rich outdoor program that's
planned and executed by the Scouts.
I do understand they can't do everything, but they're not
Cub Scouts anymore either.
We do train our new leaders.
I have an active outdoor coordinator and celebral,
very involved assistant scout masters.
My answer back to Todd was basically I think it's
three words: time, patience and persistence.
This does not happen overnight
And just because we train youth in these things, training
has nothing to do with the development of skill.
Let me say that again.
Training really doesn't have a whole lot to do with the
development of skill.
Training basically gets people OK. so this is how it
works.
Now you know, go out and give it a try a few times.
That's where the development of the skill comes in.
So I think sometimes we could lessen our frustrations by
having a realistic expectation of exactly what training
will do for us.
Training will do for us very little if the concepts and
the practices that we work on in training don't get put into
practice and build over a incremental period of time.
Time, patience and persistence is what's going
to make it happen.
Now, if things are really off the rails and not going
quite so well- which my sense is that they're going OK-
It's just a little aggravating because boys don't
plan very well.
They're horrible planners.
They really are,
And this is. you have to make up your mind that this is one
of the things that you're going to deal with,
And the way that you get them to start thinking about
planning is you get them to start thinking.
And the way you get them to start thinking is by
asking them questions.
So if you sit down with your senior patrol leader and you
say here's the list of things that have to happen for
this camp out, how are you going to make it happen?
And then get very specific,
Keep asking questions until you've drilled down to his
thinking through a specific plan,
If you hand him a sheet of paper with a plan on it or
some kind of planning matrix where he fills in the blanks,
it's not going to work very well.
Get him to start thinking in small, incremental steps
about each piece of the plan by asking questions,
And that will really start to work.
Trust me, it will really start to work.
It will take repetition, patience, persistence and
repetition, but it will work.
After you've done this, after you've sat down and you've
questioned the senior patrol leader about what his plans
are, how he's making them, how has he recorded them,
suspend judgment and observe what happens next.
Don't judge.
And it's hard to do because you're emotionally involved
with your program.
If you're the scout master, it's your troop and your
program and you're going to be emotionally involved in
its success.
But what you have to do is you have to kind of suspend
that judgment and just observe, as if you are an
anthropologist in a blind watching a herd of antelopes
somewhere.
That's what you want to do
And see what happens. OK,
And you'll see more if you take up that observer
position. all right,
Study the communications, what the scouts say to
each other, look for the least little bit of
success or initiative and then step out of the
blind and encourage them.
Hey, I was really happy to see that you guys
were talking about transportation and it's
three weeks ahead of the event.
That's really great.
If you need any help with that, make sure to let us
know.
I really appreciate that you are thinking ahead,
Little pats on the back like that.
Study that and analyze it and discuss your findings
with the other people involved, with the troop, your
assistant scout masters, and see what you can do
to keep advancing the cause.
Tiny steps, tiny steps.
This all happens incrementally over weeks, months,
years, as you build your confidence in the
scouts and you build their skills,
And each successive group that has this set of
responsibilities it's going to be adding just
little bits at a time
And then, once they become competent, it's time
for them to move on in the next group to take over.
As I said, as laudable as training is, as good
as it is, it's only the beginning of a very
long process
And we're tempted to think that train means skills,
but, as I said before, it doesn't. train means they
have the information, but they certainly haven't
learned how to use it.
I like what Sean Cleary had to say.
He added in: he says it's kind of like the
old Johnny Cash song, one piece at a time.
Yeah, if you remember that song, it's about
a guy who works, I think, at an auto assembly
plant and he builds his own car by taking
a piece of the car from the plant home every
night and, you know, ends up with his own car
after a while.
The Scouts really want to do these things.
This is what Sean said.
He Scouts want to do these tasks, but they
don't really know where to begin.
We've been doing this for so long,
We don't really know any different
And we just have to reach out and help
them and do it one piece at a time.
Okay,
Jack Thornton added this.
He said, let's face it, if all we were
concerned with were successful activities,
we wouldn't need the Scouts to be
involved in making them happen.
All right,
Jack had that's a really great insight
there.
Let me read that again:
If all we are concerned with is
successful activities, we wouldn't
need the Scouts to be involved in
making them happen.
The reason that we're going camping,
the reason we're having meetings, the
reason there's something to plan,
is not so that the end product- that
camping trip, the meeting, whatever,
that's not the end product that we're
looking for.
We want that to happen, but the end
product is the process of planning.
Jack goes on to say: since our goals
are not activity focused, we can
afford to step back and let mistakes
happen, as long as they're not health
and safety issues and we coach and
counsel those involved so they learn
what went wrong and how to avoid them
in the future.
I added: I'd also want you to take
an honest, long look at how the
adults are involved in the process.
It sounds like there's probably a
little bit of hovering going on
Now. Todd, that's not a criticism.
it's just an observation.
I deal with this in my troop all the
time.
You may have set a precedent that
the adults will, in the end, step in
and fix everything.
You also note that it's stressful.
This means there's some kind of
resentment and possibly anger
involved and at a minimum, there's
some frustration involved.
Scouts are always going to defer to
adults.
If an adult is in the room,
Scouts are looking at him to see
what he's going to say next.
If an adult is supposed to help the
scout plan, guess who's going to end
up doing the planning? most of the
time,
The adult
Scouts are going to defer to them.
They're trained to do that.
Okay,
That's the way that they have been
brought up.
You may have too many voices advising
them and they're getting cross
signals, or they may be so confused
and kind of dispirited about the whole
thing that they simply are going to
wait until you guys step in and
fix things.
I had this kind of an issue on our
last backpacking trip.
Four very helpful adults separately
advised the senior patrol leader on
how to filter water at our Saturday
campsite and each time he got some
advice about it he changed his
plans to suit them and by the time
he- you know he listened to the fourth
adult, advised him about that, he was
pretty confused and he wasn't really
sure what to do. and at that point he
kind of said: look, you know, why don't
you guys just do it?
If you're going to come and tell me
how to do this all the time, you guys
can go, just do it.
Now he didn't actually say that, but
his actions reflected that attitude.
And standing orders for adults are
nobody but the scout master or
his go-to designee advises or
instructs youth leaders in the field,
unless there's an intimate danger to
health and safety.
That's really, really important because
otherwise, you know, there's a lot of
people who want to be helpful,
there's a lot of helpful advice and
sometimes it can go across purposes
with each other and you want to
watch out that you're not confusing
the scouts and that you're not
putting adults in places where
they're going to be automatically
deferred to by the scouts.
And even though you know I talk
about this all the time here,
even though I write about it, even
though I think about it all the time,
hey, we still all have our share of
these difficulties and problems
and these difficulties and problems
are scouting.
They are scouting.
They're not something to be eliminated.
This is the way that it works:
Imperfect plans halting difficult
plans, you know things that don't
come out as they're supposed to.
That's the process that we want our
scouts to go through and that's what
we want them to learn from.
So persistence, patience, perseverance.
do it over and over and over again.
ask a lot of questions, do a lot of
talking, hand out praise and
add a boys like they were candy.
Make sure that you always tell the
guys when they do a good job
and over time things will develop
and you'll get what you're looking for, Todd.
You'll get that kind of thing where
they're doing more planning than not
and they're making successful steps
in going through the process.
that is really at the heart of scouting.
This email came in from a listener
asked to remain anonymous.
He said: here's something that I thought
when I was paging through the Cub
Scout section of the New Guide to
Advancement. In section 4,
there's a statement that says this:
We Below Scouts who have earned the
Arrow of Light Award have also
completed most of the requirements
for Scout Patch.
This can easily be completed and
presented when the boy has joined
the troop and the Scout Master has
signed for the accomplishment in the
Boy Scout Handbook.
Now my listener goes on to say:
I interpret that to mean that
since these requirements were already
completed and approved by his
We Below's den leader,
the boy does not need to repeat them
in front of the troop for credit
towards the Scout Badge.
About the only thing he needs to do
with the troop is have a Scout
Master's Conference and complete
the child protection exercises
in the front of his handbook with his
parents.
Yet in some cases there seems to
be a notion that the troop needs
to spend endless time
getting them to scout.
After they cross over, the new boys
are assigned to work with current
Scouts, going over things like the
Scout Sign and the Handshake,
relearning the Oath and Law
and trying a Square Knot.
They sometimes wait until all the
We Below Scouts have crossed over
before beginning the process
and then they have cases where
six months later
the boy still hasn't been
recorded as a Scout because
those requirements weren't signed off.
Here's the way I think it should
happen.
A We Below Scout with his Arrow
of Light Badge- his Scout Book
had a completed application which
was given to him at his
Arrow of Light ceremony-
shows up at the troop meeting.
During that first troop meeting
he has a conference with the
Scout Master, who reviews the
joining requirements with him
and checks to see if the
parent exercises have been
completed.
The Scout Master signs his book,
notifies the advancement chair
and informs the senior patrol
leader that there is a new Scout
who should be recognized at the
end of the troop meeting.
As long as everything is in order,
he should walk out of that very
first troop meeting with a
Scout badge in hand.
Anything less than that, and it
seems like we're throwing road
blocks in his way.
So, Clark, what's your take on the
applicability of Arrow of Light
requirements toward the Scout
badge and how do you handle it
in your troop?
Well, I really appreciate you,
having been in touch, for
pointing this out again, and this
has always been true.
Let me re-read the exact
wording of that sentence from the
Guide to Advancement.
We Below Scouts who have earned
the Arrow of Light Award have also
completed most of the
requirements for Scout badge.
This can easily be completed and
then presented when the boy has
joined a troop and the Scout
master assigned the accomplishment
in the Boy Scout Handbook.
So here's my take:
If a boy comes with the Arrow of
Light badge. I think I would
probably want to start handling it
exactly as you describe it.
Make it quick, simple and easy.
There's no reason for a boy who's
already earned this
learned the Scout Oath,
because most of them will come
having memorized the Scout Oath
and the Scout law at one point.
Okay, but if you remember,
for the Scout badge it doesn't
say have it memorized,
It doesn't say repeat it from memory.
It says understand and intend to
live by the Scout Oath and law.
Yeah, so we're not- hopefully not-
making them recite the Scout Oath
and law for the Scout badge.
All right, and you're right
That Scout badge should appear
lickety-split.
It should happen within the first
couple of meetings that a boy
comes to join your troop,
And that can happen
whether he is a We Below Scout
with an Arrow of Light
or a boy who's just kind of come
right off the street
and joined your troop.
And you're exactly right-
I think a lot of times we put
too much emphasis on dragging that
out for an unknown reason-
That Scout badge should get in
his hands and get on his uniform
as soon as possible.
How do I handle it in my troop?
Well, now that I've read this
and you've reminded me of this
pretty darn poorly,
to tell you the truth.
So I am now armed- and I really
appreciate your reflection on that-
And now I am armed with some renewed
information so that when we approach
having the We Blows crossover
and join our troop,
we're going to get those guys
with the Arrow of Light
and we're going to make sure
that we get them their Scout badge
right away.
And we're going to get the guys
without the Arrow of Light
and we're going to make sure
that they get their Scout badge
right away.
And whenever any boy joins the troop,
he's going to get that Scout badge
just as soon as possible.
So that was a great year in mind here
and I really appreciate it.
I hope that helps everyone else too.
Well, thank you for listening to this
edition of the Scoutmaster Podcast.
Here's how you can keep in touch.
You can read the Scoutmaster blog
at scoutmastercgcom.
You can subscribe to the Scoutmaster
podcast on iTunes.
Did you know that
That's right?
When you do, hey,
leave a comment or review a rating
there on iTunes.
That always is encouraging
and helpful.
You can also access the podcast
on your mobile device
through Stitcher Smart Radio
and you can get details
about how to do that.
It's very, very simple. at Stitcher
S-T-I-T-C-H-E-Rcom.
Did you hear Chad earlier?
What he did is he picked up the
phone and he called
4-8-4-7-3-4-0-0-2..
You can call and leave a voicemail,
comment or question.
You can sing me a nice song.
You can wish me happy holidays,
Whatever you'd like to do,
4-8-4-7-3-4-0-0-0-2..
Apparently, I could use a few new
jokes. if you listened from the
beginning,
I could probably use a few new
jokes.
4-8-4-7-3-4-0-0-0-2..
You can experience all the
wonders of scoutmastercgcom
through the vast panorama
of social media outlets.
That's right.
You can follow us at
Scoutmaster blog on Facebook,
tweet scoutmastercg
on Twitter and, for admittance
to the exclusive scoutmastercg
circle,
Search for scoutmastercg
on Google plus.
You don't face,
You don't tweet,
You don't plus.
That's all right. Bunky,
You can email me,
That's right.
Good old fashioned email will
work.
And the way to get in touch
is scoutmastercg
at Verizonnet-
Scoutmastercg
at Verizonnet.
It only remains for me to tell
you that the scoutmaster blog
and the scoutmaster
podcast are not official
publications of the Boy Scouts
of America,
nor are they endorsed or
sponsored by the Boy Scouts
of America.
Goodness, now
It's just me,
That's right.
One of your fellow
volunteers talking into a
microphone trying to lend a
hand to the scout leaders
and maybe have a little bit
of fun while we did.
Before we leave you today,
let's hear from our founder,
Sir Robert Bidden Powell.
Sir Robert,
I highly recommend
the scoutmaster podcast.
Good luck to you
and good camping,
Why? thank you, sir,
Until next time.